so we've been talking about the
gettysburg address which was delivered
by abraham lincoln on november 19 1863
and as we were saying in the last video
it's been about three and a half months
since the battle of gettysburg when this
speech is given and lincoln himself is
not even the headliner at this ceremony
of dedicating the cemetery he is just
supposed to give a few appropriate
remarks while the famous orator edward
everett gives the really bombastic
two-hour long speech that is gonna rile
up the crowd and make everyone
understand the importance of the battle
and the importance of the cemetery that
is being dedicated but somehow the 272
words that lincoln says here in the
gettysburg address has become one of the
most famous and important pieces of
rhetoric in american history so in this
video i'd like to just take a little
time to read the gettysburg address and
to interpret it line by line to give a
better sense of what it's trying to say
and why it's so important all right so
let's see if i can do this justice
for score and seven years ago
our fathers brought forth on this
continent a new nation conceived in
liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal
now we are engaged in a great civil war
testing whether that nation or any
nation so conceived and so dedicated can
long endure
we are met on a great battlefield of
that war
we've come to dedicate a portion of that
field as a final resting place for those
who here gave their lives that that
nation might live
it is all together fitting and proper
that we should do this
but in a larger sense
we cannot dedicate we cannot consecrate
we cannot hallow this ground
the brave men living and dead who
struggled here have consecrated it far
above our poor power to add or detract
the world will little note nor long
remember what we say here but it can
never forget what they did here it is
for us the living rather to be dedicated
here to the unfinished work which they
who fought here have thus far so nobly
advanced it is rather for us to be here
dedicated to the great task remaining
before us that from these honored dead
we take increased devotion to that cause
for which they gave the last full
measure of devotion that we here highly
resolve that these dead shall not have
died in vain that this nation under god
shall have a new birth of freedom
and that government of the people by the
people for the people shall not perish
from the earth wow it gives me chills
just reading this and there's just
something about lincoln's oratory the
way that he puts things that just rivets
you and this is why he was such a great
leader and such a great politician
because he knew how to use words to his
advantage and he knew how to touch
people with what he had to say now it's
more than 150 years later and we still
read this and memorize it in school and
think about it on kind of a regular
basis because we frequently quote the
words that he said here so how did this
get to be so important well let's read
it line by line and see what he's really
saying all right so four score and seven
years ago our fathers brought forth on
this continent a new nation conceived in
liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal all right
well
this
case you're wondering means 87 years
four score a score is 20. in fact some
of the newspapers that printed the text
of this speech just said 87 years ago so
why doesn't lincoln just say 87 well i
think this four score and seven years
ago
has this really strong i would even say
like biblical ring right it has this
importance and eloquence of oratory so
he's already setting the tone to say
here in this nation we are measuring
time almost biblically like this is a
sacred mission and it's been a sacred
amount of time since the founding of the
nation i think it's really interesting
to note that it's only 87 years between
1776 and 1863
i know this is just basic math but
between the founding of the united
states and the civil war when the union
fought for its very survival was less
than a hundred years it's a very short
period of time now lincoln as a young
man would have known older men who had
fought in the revolutionary war andrew
jackson for example so lincoln starts
out by saying that less than a hundred
years ago the united states was founded
and it was founded on this principle
that all men are created equal now if
you contrast that with the system of
slavery which the south is fighting to
preserve that is definitely in contra
distinction to the concept that all men
are created equal so lincoln reminds his
audience immediately that the founding
principles of the united states were
equality and liberty alright so he moves
on to say now we are engaged in a great
civil war testing whether that nation or
any nation so conceived and so dedicated
can long endure
so in less than a hundred years
the idea that held the united states
together is now being tested and he's
reminding people that the world is
watching
they're saying all right there's this
upstart democracy in the americas saying
that monarchy which has been the rule of
europe for
more than a thousand years is a silly
proposition and they can do better well
now look at them they're fighting a
civil war because some folks want to be
the masters of others and some folks
don't think that's all right so in a way
what lincoln is reminding people here is
that they're engaged in this grand
experiment right this grand experiment
of liberty and equality where no one is
the master of anyone else where any
person like abraham lincoln born in a
log cabin less than a year of school in
his entire life can become president so
if the democracy of the united states
fails if this union falls apart then it
will have proved the doubters right that
democracy doesn't work and then he
continues we are met on a great
battlefield of that war we've come to
dedicate a portion of that field as a
final resting place for those who here
gave their lives that that nation might
live
it is all together fitting and proper
that we should do this i think there are
two important things here so he talks
about the concept of a nation
and this is really interesting because
prior to the civil war it was frequent
that people might say things like these
united states
right the idea
that the states are the most prominent
portion of the country and that the
individual states
plural were together in a union that was
secondary to the idea of statehood but
midway through the war lincoln starts to
use the word nation more and more and
afterwards
it will always be known as the
united states so lincoln is signaling
here that this is one united nation
not just a collection of states and that
is what the american forces are fighting
for that is what the forces of the
united states are trying to achieve a
united nation
not a united set of states the other
interesting thing here is that he
mentions it's all together fitting and
proper
that we should do this why wouldn't it
be proper to dedicate a cemetery well a
lot of people thought that it wasn't
proper for lincoln to be speaking at
this ceremony dedication they thought
that it was kind of a cheap political
maneuvering imagine today if the
president went to a soldier's funeral
many people might say it's not
appropriate for the president to be
there because it's just a political
opportunity right that you're trying to
get votes from somebody else's tragedy
and it's kind of ironic because
lincoln's speech here is very
sacred very funeral whereas everett's
speech was very political saying this
was a great battle we have to remember
that the confederates are our enemies
but lincoln's speech is much gentler
much kinder much more appropriate
actually to a funeral perhaps than
everett's speech but he feels it
necessary to remind people that it is
appropriate to gather here together to
mark the dedication of this cemetery
even though many might decry it as just
political grandstanding now i think it's
this next paragraph that makes the
gettysburg address so powerful so let's
read it in a larger sense
we cannot dedicate we cannot consecrate
we cannot hallow this ground
the brave men living and dead who
struggled here have consecrated it far
above our poor power to add or detract
the world will little note nor long
remember what we say here but it can
never forget what they did here so he's
drawing attention to the importance of
the battlefield dead he says this is not
about us it's about them they have
sacrificed they have become martyrs for
this cause so we cannot consecrate the
cemetery they have already consecrated
it with their blood and with their
sacrifice so he's reminding everyone of
the sacrifice
and the martyrdom
of the battlefield dead
now here's the real power of the
gettysburg address the last couple of
sentences let's read them all together
it is for us the living rather to be
dedicated here to the unfinished work
which they who fought here have thus far
so nobly advanced it is rather for us
to be here dedicated to the great task
remaining before us
that from these honored dead we take
increased devotion to that cause for
which they gave the last full measure of
devotion
that we here highly resolve that these
dead shall not have died in vain that
this nation under god shall have a new
birth of freedom
and that government of the people by the
people for the people shall not perish
from the earth
what lincoln does here is so powerful
because it's kind of a rhetorical
switcheroo he says we're not here to
dedicate the cemetery the cemetery is
here to dedicate us
men have died here and we must honor
their martyrdom
we must honor their sacrifice
for the experiment of liberty and
equality by taking renewed dedication to
that cause so come to the battlefield of
gettysburg come to this cemetery and
take renewed heart in the mission of
continuing democracy continuing equality
and continuing to fight for a united
states of america and how the rest of
those battles play out we'll get to in
the next video